Did you know that people usually decide
if they respect you within the first
minute of meeting you? Sometimes that
takes as few as just five seconds, which
goes for both good and bad impressions.
So, you give me 7 minutes, I will teach
you five psychological tricks that you
can use to command respect instantly.
And these will build habits that make
that respect last. First is something
you can do before you even speak to
someone. And that is to fill up your
calendar. because people subconsciously
associate limited availability with
higher value. Now, the flip of this is
being free whenever you are. And
although that flexibility is meant as a
kindness, it can actually make people
more likely to show up late or flake.
And that is true in business. It's true
in friendships and in dating. So, the
way to build respect here is to
purposely fill your calendar with real
commitments, even if they're just for
you. That can mean blocking out time for
the gym, your hobbies, or your favorite
TV show. For me, every Sunday evening
was sacred for Game of Thrones for a
long time. I wish I was the monster you
think I am. Which means that when you're
scheduling with anyone, you will
naturally say things like, "I'm free
Thursday at noon or Wednesday at 2 p.m.,
which works for you." When you do that,
you find that people actually put more
effort into connecting, into showing up
to that time than if you kindly but
foolishly break your commitments to try
to accommodate other people. Now the
second key point is evolutionary and it
has to do with how we move and direct
our attention. You see we unconsciously
know that those rapid jerky movements of
prey animals are associated with fear
because those animals are doing that to
scan the horizon for threats. Now on the
other hand we sense that those slow
comfortable movements of predator
animals that don't need to react to
everything are associated with power and
safety. Now humans are both prey and
predator. So when we see humans do one
or the other, we will unconsciously feel
uncomfortable when they're behaving in
that prey way and very relaxed when
they're in that more predator mode.
Doesn't mean that they're dangerous,
just means that they're slow. So there's
tons of ways to practice this confident
quality of your movements. But one very
easy way is to make sure that when
you're speaking to someone that you
don't let someone else interrupting you
rip your attention away. You don't let
every noise capture you. So, if you're
talking and someone cuts in with a
question, don't immediately let that
interruption dictate where your
attention goes. You let the other person
finish or you finish and then you come
back to that person with something like,
"Hey, good to see you. What were you
asking about?" Now, when you do this,
both the person that was listening to
you and the person who actually
interrupted you, who wanted your
attention, are going to respect you more
since your attention can't be ripped
away by any little thing. Now, this
third point has to do again with how we
direct our attention, but it's for
people that go too far in the direction
of that second point. Because yes, you
don't want to let people completely
control your attention, but some people
will then make the mistake of not
acknowledging others at all. So, they'll
be walking down the sidewalk, see
someone else with headphones in, and
they won't even look at them. They'll
just, you know, down or away. Or they
know someone at the gym that they've
spoken to once or twice, and that person
has dumbbells when they arrive, and they
don't know whether they should, you
know, wave or make eye contact or greet
them. So they just kind of again down.
Or if you go into a crowded meeting room
of a bunch of colleagues, you might feel
like I can't say hi to everybody, so I
guess I just wave awkwardly. Now, the
principle that actually builds respect
here is to extend yourself further than
you normally do, and most people do when
it comes to acknowledging and greeting
others. That means letting friendly eye
contact linger on the stranger on the
sidewalk, even if it's not reciprocated.
means going up to that guy that you met
at the gym and giving him a quick clap
on the back if he's between sets or just
a big wave if you don't want to disrupt
him while he's working out. And in a
crowded meeting room, it might mean that
you shake hands with at least one more
person than you normally would. Even if
that means you have to walk around a
table and go out of your way to do so.
Now, when you do this, obviously people
are going to feel appreciated, but
they'll also respect you because you
bailed them out of that uncomfortable
uncertainty of if they should
acknowledge you or not. And it's a
simple way to mark yourself as a leader
in any situation. Now, the next point is
all about filler words. We all know that
you shouldn't say uh um or like. And we
try not to. But most people don't know
is that words like amazing and that's so
cool can crush your respectability in
the same way as those other words. And
that is because even though it can feel
like, hey, I'm just trying to be
enthusiastic. Those phrases sometimes
will make the other person feel that
you're overly impressed for no reason.
And they're likely to try to withdraw
from you as they wonder why you're
buttering them up. So instead, what you
want to do is eliminate inauthentic
compliments. Only compliment people when
you are genuinely moved to appreciation.
When people feel that you're being
sincere, something that you noticed
about them, they are going to respect
it, rather than think you're just some
sort of a nice guy that wants something
from them. And if you really, really try
to give compliments on every occasion
that you feel appreciation, you will
wind up giving way more compliments,
starting way more conversations than if
you just use compliments as some sort of
uncomfortable lubricant in conversation.
So, this pairs very well with the point
about greeting people. You put them
together. Now, part of the reason that
we add those filler words sometimes is
because we feel pressure that we need to
have something useful to say constantly
in conversations. And this next point
helps deal with that. It's something
that I've actually become infamous for
on YouTube. So, whether you're giving
yourself three or five or 10 seconds,
the rule is that we give ourselves so
much less time than we offer to others
when it comes to silence. So, we need to
recognize that and give ourselves the
same amount of space that we would offer
to them. Which means that pure silence
is totally fine as you gather your
thoughts after someone asks you a
question or even if you're midstory.
Now, if you feel like you need some sort
of crutch words, try hm, let me think
about that. We've seen Dr. K do that a
ton and it actually makes the other
person feel very listened to. So, I'm
going to toss something out there. Sure.
Can I think for a second? And though it
might feel sometimes like that clock is
ticking, got to say something, actually
gathering yourself, taking a moment,
draws attention to you because it shows
that you're reflecting deeply on what
that person has said or what you want to
say next. If you listen to the greatest
storytellers like Dave Chappelle, just
notice how much silence is in their
stories. Then I looked over in the
corner and there was a there was a
box custommade jerseys for the local
team. Each one was handstitched and on
the back they stitched on the K heart on
all of them. Kevin saw me staring at
that box and he went over and grabbed
one of them
jerseys and he walked right to my son.
He said, "Hey little man, I want you to
have this." So give yourself that same
space, that same grace. Take a moment,
slow down in interaction. It will help a
ton. And I acknowledge that yes,
implementing everything I just said can
be tricky. like which of these are you
supposed to do first? How do you make
these effortless instead of feeling like
a test? So, if you're interested in the
fastest way that I know of to make this
stuff effortless, you might be
interested in my course, Charisma
University. You get full details at the
link here. But basically, if you like
the YouTube channel and charisma
confidence building respect is a
priority for you, I highly encourage you
to click the link, check it out, learn
more, and maybe join. Either way, I hope
that you have enjoyed this video and I
look forward to seeing you in the next